so we have a number line here with zero
at the center and then on that number
line we've marked off some numbers so to
the left of the number line we have the
number a
and then we have the number b here a
little bit closer to zero and then on
the right side of zero we have the
number c
and then after that we have a bunch of
statements dealing with inequalities and
what i want you to do is pause the video
and think about which of these
statements are true which of these
statements are false and maybe which of
these statements you don't have enough
information to figure out
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it
did you you've tried to figure out which
of these are true which are these are
false and which of these you can't
figure out so let's let's do them
together
so this first statement says negative b
is less than negative c
so we do know for a fact that b is less
than c
we know
we know that
b
is less than c how do we know that well
b is to the left of c on the number line
it's that straightforward so we know
this
this is definitely true but what about
negative b is negative b less than
negative c
so let's think about where negative b is
on this number line so negative b
i will do an yellow
so negative that's negative b means the
opposite of b so if b is one hash mark
to the left of zero negative b is going
to be one hash mark to the right of zero
so that right over there is going to be
negative b
and now where is negative c
once again negative c this literally
means the opposite of c
c is
one two three four five hash marks to
the right of zero and so negative c is
going to be one two three four five hash
marks to the left of zero and actually
let me do this in a different color so
negative c i will do in purple this
right over here
is
negative c
so let's compare is negative b
less than negative c
no negative b is to the right of
negative c on the number line negative b
is greater than negative c so this is
not true
negative b is to the right of negative c
negative b is greater than negative c
and if this is a little confusing just
think about it since b is a negative
number negative b
negative b is going to be a positive
number and since c is a positive number
negative c is going to be a negative
number is going to be a negative number
so it makes complete sense that a
positive number is going to be greater
than a negative number and you see it
here negative b is to the right of
negative c on the number line so we can
rule this one out
so the next question is negative b
greater than zero
well we already plotted negative b it's
going to be one to the right or one hash
mark to the right we don't know how many
how much each of these hash marks
represent but it's going to be to the
right of zero so it is greater than zero
this is true
that is true
all right now is a
greater than b
well let's look at it a is to the left
of b on the number line a is more
negative than b
so a is less than b not greater than b
so this is not going to be the case in
order for something to be greater than
something else it would have to be to
the right of it for a to be greater than
b would have to be to the right of b but
we see a is to the left of b a is less
than b
all right one more to think about
negative a is greater than c
so we know that a isn't greater than c a
is to the left of c a is a negative
number it's to the left of zero c is a
positive number is to the right of zero
but what about negative a
well let's let's draw that let me do
this in a color that i haven't used yet
negative a where would that be
well a is one two three four five 6
hash marks to the left of 0.
and so negative a is going to be 6 hash
marks to the right of 0. so let's count
that
1 2
3 4 5 6.
so negative a
is going to be right over there and
notice negative a
is to the right of c so negative a is
greater than c this is true and if you
get confused if you're like wait this
looks like a this looks like a negative
how can it be larger than a positive
remember negative a itself is a negative
number and a itself is six hash marks to
the left
so if you take the opposite of that
you're going to get a positive number
you're going to get six hash marks to
the right and c which was already a
positive number is only five hash marks
to the right and so negative a this is
going to be a positive number
and it's going to be greater than c it's
to the right of c